le film la haine s'inspire de cet
événement tragique voici l'histoire de
macome un adolescent de 17 ans tué d'une
balle dans la tête par un policier
touché par une balle tirée par l'arme du
policier qui l'interrogeait dans un
commissariat menotté ce matin tout le
monde parle de bavure comme on a
aujourd'hui dans ce pays on peut se
lever le matin et se prendre une balle
dans la tête le soir
[Applaudissements]
nous sommes dans la nuit du 6 avril 1993
à Paris vers 4h30 du matin trois jeunes
hommes sont interpellés par la police et
conduit au commissariat des grandes
carrières dans le 18e arrondissement
ils ont décidé de cambrioler un tabac en
extrait des cartouches de cigarettes de
façon à les vendre ensuite à la crevette
ma communauté jeune homme de 17 ans qui
habite dans le 20e arrondissement sur
les bâtiments qui donnent sur les
périphériques il fait partie d'une
famille de zaïrois il était un peu connu
des services de police locaux pour avoir
fait quelques petits vols et c'est ce
qu'il a amené à faire ce larcin qui la
conduit à être placé en garde à vue les
trois jeunes hommes avouent un vol dans
une camionnette mais pas le vol de
cigarettes alors que le parquet ordonne
la levée de la garde à vue en fin de
matinée les suspects sont relâchés à
l'exception de makomé la police n'arrive
pas à joindre ses parents pour qu'ils
viennent le chercher et puis dans
l'intervalle
le policier à ce qu'elle Compain aurait
une information qui pourrait faire
évoluer l'enquête conserve ma commune au
commissariat et c'est à ce moment-là que
ce produit pire le ton serait monté
durant une garde à vue entre un
inspecteur et la victime qui était déjà
connue des services de police la
provocation s'installe Pascal compas
s'empare de son arme qui était dans son
tiroir et tire
sur ma commune dans un commissariat
menotté l'écrit et les larmes d'une
famille Mako
âgée de 17 ans leur fils leur frère a
été tué hier au cours de sa garde à vue
touché par une balle tirée par l'arme du
policier qui l'interrogeait
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
des poches
encore une fois mais cette faute doit
pouvoir être placé aussi dans le
contexte où je parlais de contexte de
ces conditions de travail absolument
épouvantables il faut le souligner la
hiérarchie policière à
dire lâcher Pascal confort le rôle de la
police
dès lors qu'il y aura des photographes
de remise elle sera les responsable
seront sanctionnés
commissaire des grandes carrières et
rapidement suspendu quant à Pascal
Compain le policier responsable de la
mort de macomé il est inculpé pour
homicide volontaire et placé en
détention provisoire
immédiatement après l'annonce des drames
des jeunes s'enflamment on est en 93 et
vous n'avez pas de réseaux sociaux donc
c'est le bouche à oreille qui fait que
une manifestation a été organisée
une protestation solennelle 24 heures
après la mort du jeune macomé 250
personnes environ devant le commissariat
des grandes carrières face à face tendue
avec les gendarmes mobiles la
manifestation se voulait symbolique elle
est devenue violente cette manifestation
marque le début de 3 jours de violence
entre les forces de police et des jeunes
manifestants qui réclament justice pour
Macomer pour la deuxième soirée
consécutive hier les mêmes scènes
d'affrontement de vandalisme
hier soir il était bien difficile pour
la famille du jeune macomé de faire
comprendre à tous qu'elle souhaitait se
recueillir dans la dignité et le calme
deux ans après la mort de macomé le film
la haine réalisé par Mathieu Kassovitz
sort en salle
l'idée de ce film vous est venue
d'ailleurs d'une bavure policière il y a
une série de bavures en 93 il y a eu
yamako me qui s'est fait tirer une balle
dans la tête dans un commissariat du 18e
l'histoire se déroule dans une cité de
la région parisienne au lendemain d'une
nuit d'émeutes après qu'un jeune homme a
été tabassé par un policier dans un
commissariat la haine est un film qui
raconte 24 heures de trois jeunes gens
de la banlieue
mais c'est aussi à la bidence un film
anti-flic
c'est pas un film anti policier dans le
sens primaire du sujet c'est vraiment
c'est un film anti
le système qui fait que la police est
comme elle est même vous n'avez pas la
haine des flics il y a des bons flics et
les mauvais flics j'avais des mauvais
flics quoi ce film traduit très
précisément l'état d'esprit des jeunes
le ressentiment qu'ils ont d'être
méprisés le mépris à cause des
frustrations telles qu'au bout d'un
moment elles explosent et elles
explosent mal
un procès sensible s'ouvre de mains
devant les assises de Paris le procès du
policier parce qu'elle compare ce
policier du 18e arrondissement a tué le
zaïrois du 17 ans le jeune macomé risque
30 ans de prison
selon ses supérieurs parce qu'elle
Compain était un piètre policier mais il
n'est ni bagarreur ni violent c'est un
homme qui est absolument pas violent
donc cet acte est incompréhensible ça ne
s'inscrit pas dans ce qu'il est à
l'évidence il a été
où c'est à bout il inspecteur Pascal
Compain s'est défendu d'avoir tiré sur
macome et mbollé il a eu un mouvement
vers moi j'ai sorti un choc j'ai eu un
mouvement de réflexe et le coup est
parti à expliquer le gardien de la paix
j'ai le sentiment aujourd'hui comme pour
pas uniquement se contenter de faire le
procès d'un policier sans reposer la
question de responsabilité collective et
y compris de la réarchie policière
troisième journée du procès de
l'inspecteur Compain devant la Cour
d'assise de Paris la justice s'est
penché aujourd'hui sur les antécédents
de la victime la famille je me souviens
quand même très bien du procès et
c'était c'était extrêmement douloureux
appelé à décrire son fils aîné la mère
de ma commune a pu dire que sa peine de
l'avoir perdue assise sur une chaise
accoudé à la barre des témoins elle
pleure cela me fait mal d'entendre dire
que ma communauté méchant il avait volé
des cigarettes mais on aurait pu les
rembourser il ne méritait pas la mort
Pascal Compain et comme finalement de 8
ans de prison ferme soit 2 ans de moins
que les réquisitions de l'avocat général
décrit et une manifestation de
protestation ont accueilli le verdict
selon les proches de la victime l'ex
inspecteur compas condamné à 8 ans de
prison pour couper blessures et ont
entraîner la mort sans intention de la
donner sentira trop bon contre je
croyais à une vraie justice mais là on
vient d'assister à une véritable parodie
de la justice une justice qui est
purement raciste la justice elle elle
est rendue elle doit être rendue en
tenant compte de tous les éléments d'un
dossier et je pense que cette décision a
été rendue d'une manière sereine à
l'issue du procès Pascal compas a
déclaré c'est lourd à porter la mort
d'un homme ce drame puisse-t-il servir
pour que si un jour un policier voit son
arme il manque de son froid il se
rappelle qu'il y a eu un mort et que
cela n'arrive plus jamais sincère ou pas
sincère ces mots ils existent
et ils n'ont pas eu d'écho
aucun la preuve l'histoire se répète